John Oliver just released another video
or segment that has been turned into a
video on nuclear waste now here's the
deal I think Don Oliver is very funny I
think the second actually is a lot of
funny bits but John Oliver I will say
this and we'll get to why it is entirely
wrong on nuclear power as a matter of
fact it's not going nearly as viral as
others because most people know that he
has no idea as to what he's talking
about
but uh he's gotten so lazy it's become a
formula and it's easy to pick out where
we don't have this ser surely they have
to rebut you know a 20-minute segment
because about 65% of it is anecdotal
fear-mongering so does the same thing
here what he does he just he presents a
problem okay then he talks about how
terrible the problem is and he ignores
the fact that Democrats have created the
problem and Republicans tried to fix it
for a long time then he ignores any
solutions and then he ends with
restating how terrible the problem is
without offering any solutions that's
that's the segment so he does at this
time in a way that he believes to be
very effective working on it for weeks
he says with nuclear energy let's roll
the first clip nuclear waste the
radioactive and toxic byproducts from
making nuclear energy and weapons is a
serious health hazard except it's not
nuclear power generates less waste than
coal which Oliver's also against oil gas
surprisingly even less than solar and
wind with solar waste panels creating
300 times the toxic waste per unit of
energy that a nuclear power plant would
be producing if you compare them yeah so
you can say this is again they just take
statements that are not contextual they
remove the context say it's a health
hazard well at that point you can say
that cheez-its are a health hazard
because there was a recall in 1975
Harper disagrees it's not nearly the
same health hazard as botulism Monday
they could be botched those munchies I
don't know let's go to next clip one out
of three Americans live within 50 miles
of high-level nuclear waste some of
which like plutonium is lethally
dangerous and will be in will be around
for an incredibly long time lutonium 239
for example as a half-life of about
24,000 years it's true 24,000 years and
that just scratches the surface it takes
ten half-lives for plutonium to become
harmless
so that's 240,000 years
what does that aljazeera alright he
should use this point slash also
al-jazeera for his fear-mongering solar
energy okay though more expensive and
less efficient than nuclear create
substances which unlike radioactive
isotopes have actually an infinite
half-life at that point what kind of
splitting hairs infinite half-life
thousands of years I get it but coal ash
itself carries into the surrounding
environment I quote 100 times more
radiation than a nuclear power plant
producing the same amount of energy so
you can just say something is bad we get
it we get it nobody wants nuclear waste
in their backyard but when you remove
the context you don't actually help
anybody this isn't productive at a
certain point you're just fear-mongering
because that's what you do let's
continue with that clip three almost
half a century after nuclear power was
harnessed there still is no agreement on
where to store the waste it has been 27
years since that clip and our country
still doesn't have a nuclear toilet and
that is our subject tonight why do we
not have a nuclear toilet but I'll tell
you exactly why we don't have a nuclear
toilet because you because you don't
want one people like you for the same
political expediency Obama shut down you
come out and said pack our nuclear waste
repository by potentially 20 years okay
so this is wide why do we not have it do
we want to look at the policy Democrats
have repeatedly halted reprocessing of
nuclear waste too we'll get to that in
France they have their light years
beyond us and their nuclear capability
certainly what they're using so let's
look 1977 Jimmy Carter banned a nuclear
reprocessing Ronald Kray Ronald Reagan
lifted the ban in 1981 nineteen
ninety-three Clinton discouraged the
nuclear industry from reprocessing in a
policy statement 2001 george w bush
called for companies to develop
reprocessing technologies in his
national energy policy and then of
course obama came in and he screwed the
pooch once more setting it back so john
let's do this let's do this exercise
let's say that everything i tell you
when this rebuttal is true and people
who agree with john halter okay let's
say you check these sources they're not
al jazeera and you agree with the
scientists that nuclear power is i know
you have to check them and i encourage
you to watch this whole clip people out
there watching his whole segment his
whole show and i encourage you to check
the sources that we list by the way you
can just actually type them in they're
not necessarily in the description box
sorry
oh I have to type it in did you ever use
a bibliography my god the nightmare that
is a library for you so check the
sources let's assume you agree with the
sources the scientist says say nuclear
power is renewable it's reliable its
cost efficient and safe would you allow
us to open a new repository I didn't
think so and that's the point the rest
of this segment is purely fear well
before we get to that here's something I
thought was pretty interesting about
searching this story for a couple of
weeks now really because you can watch
the rest of the clip you can watch the
rest of the video and it's entirely
fear-mongering so this is the condensed
version I encourage you to watch the
whole thing over the years we have
dumped nuclear waste all over the
country and in many places there have
been frightening leaks take the Savannah
River Site in South Carolina there are
already active alligators on the site
radioactive alligators and it's not just
reptiles being impacted by a nuclear
waste I got on Facebook in order to
reconnect with people from high school
and we all immediately started noticing
but so many of us were sick we had all
of those cancers every single one
handful sites in Washington State there
have been so many issues that they've
achieved a dubious honor the most
contaminated place in the entire western
hemisphere right here in Washington
State cancer radiation alligators not
gonna lie if I said radioactive
alligator I would be pretty tariffs fun
make that a spider and I will be the
first person to buy a private ticket to
the moon so this is what John dollar
does he sets up the video with a few out
of context references so it seemed as
those sources are solid then he uses
anecdotes to fearmonger which is exactly
what the left has done by the way
specifically to shut down legislation
that would create the nuclear waste
facilities or help us with reprocessing
solutions in the first place and then
they never offer any solutions so here
the facts of nuclear energy again I
encourage you to check these sources out
it's reliable even example US Navy has
logged over 5,400 reactor years of
completely accident free operations with
nuclear submarines for the same reason
by the way that France garner 75 percent
of its energy from nuclear power and
it's so reliable and so inexpensive that
Germany's failed solar and wind energy
programs which we covered in depth
they're forced to import energy from
France when people put try to point they
have one success story they tried to
point to Germany they ended up having
energy surpluses they would send it a
sell at a net negative prices and then
they would have energy droughts by the
way their emissions when France yes
their emissions went up in Germany
because they had the solar wind how do
you think we create these farms these
plants
it requires an unbelievable amount of
energy it creates an unbelievable amount
of toxic metals and it still didn't work
so they had to import France's nuclear
power where it hasn't been politicized
yet and they have technology like
reprocessing okay it's reliable it's
safe so the actual mortality rates it's
where contact context matters from
nuclear energy are so low it's even hard
to find a graph to compare it with other
energies for scale can we bring up the
graph that we do have there you go so
see it's really it's hard you've got to
do some that's nuclear way down there
looking on it and people will say well
that graph is skewed it is skewed
because I had to find a way to fit coal
and even solar on the same graph is
nuclear so the mortality rate I think
for solar alone yeah it's over 4,000
times higher per kilowatt produced so
it's safer it's more reliable it's
incredibly clean solar power when I saw
this video I was surprised I said well
John Oliver must that he must have
nothing else to go after because even if
you look at this meal a few Larssen do
you really know anything about nuclear
energy I don't know how many ways to say
this plant in simple nuclear is cleaner
than coal gas creates a fraction of the
wastes even solar and wind farms it's
not even close I don't know how any more
ways to say it but here's the thing none
of this matters and this is my problem
with a neo environmentalist
climate alarmists so leftists oppose
nuclear for the same reason that they
have all actively opposed supposedly
green energy like solar in the Mojave
Desert yep that was stopped by the left
hydropower that's what we used in my
warehouse from in Quebec because of
endangered species and they don't want
to I don't know in interfere with the
environment it's not contaminating it
and yes even sometimes wind power as you
see with the Kennedys and their summer
homes it's a moving target that they
never intend to hit because they don't
want to see use any energy at all BAM
cult let's ban coal okay use solar okay
let's install these panels No
all right so what do we do now let's
bake let's ban for
okay let's use hydro nuclear no the fact
is that you can't point to an energy
resource the left consistently supports
at all there's not one that they've
consistently supported across the board
and certainly not one that works and
it's always John Oliver he doesn't offer
us any solutions I'm looking through his
notes here John Oliver's you didn't his
utopia okay let's present this the
United States would use no coal no gas
no hydro no fracking and no nuclear
energy and of course disarmed Americans
while exposing them to the dangers of
open unprotected borders John Oliver a
good luck with that yeah that that was
that was rougher than necessary but hey
that's what he want he specifically
requested that's utopia like this video
subscribe by clicking the subscribe
button it's act it's an Assessor chol
now it used to be a square which most
buttons aren't squares lets us on a
phone there's square buttons on phones
what mouse buttons are circles you
understand what I'm talking about or
watch the recommended video which is
popping up in a box or subscribe at
lateral credit comm flash mug club join
them on clip so you can get the Daily
Show and that means that you are not
beholden to the YouTube censoring
overlords let's be honest you like being
there where you are under their thumb
power bottom